get this one if you're a white male and
own a restaurant that's been devastated
by coveted lockdowns
you are not yet allowed to apply for
relief
just because of your gender and skin
color the bi administration has
designated the new revitalization fund
so that women and minorities get first
dibs on the limited pool of aid
for the first three weeks and if the
money runs out before white men are
eligible
too bad say goodbye to a restaurant you
shouldn't have been born
so privileged stephen miller founded
america first legal and is ready to
fight back against this in the rest of
biden's radical agenda
stephen i can barely believe the things
i read sometimes
help me here and what are you doing
about it no it seems like the craziest
ideas from a uc berkeley campus things
that we used to maybe laugh off or
dismiss
or maybe not even take seriously are now
the official
policy of the united states government i
mean it's
almost impossible to believe as you may
know
my group america first legal already
filed a lawsuit
against the usda agricultural relief
program
that explicitly excludes some farmers
from debt relief
solely based on their skin color and now
you have
a new rule which you just mentioned
which says that if your restaurant or
your bar
was absolutely decimated by the pandemic
enclosures
that you will be last in line for relief
solely
based upon your skin color it's the
institutionalization
of discrimination by the us government
that's clearly illegal
my group is going to fight it and if you
visit aflegal.org you'll find out more
about what we're doing but basically
critical race theory that insane
left-wing
campus extremism that have been talked
about so much
is now being used to decide how u.s
dollars are doled out to u.s citizens
we're going to get to the critical race
theory part in a moment but first
who in the in the white house legal
office would think that hey
if we discriminate again against someone
based on the color of their skin
that's totally constitutional that's
great i mean
they can't believe this will hold up on
scrutiny
i think that they think that people just
aren't going to be courageous enough to
challenge it
because they think that people will
assume they'll get called racist
for fighting these policies let's be
very clear you
don't solve past discrimination with
future discrimination yes
you do not solve the problem of racism
that occurred
in previous historical periods by
institutionalizing racism
today senator scott spoke about this in
his address
john roberts chief justice roberts wrote
about this in the past too
if you allow the government to decide
whose business survives and whose
business dies just based on the
pigmentation of their skin
then you have violated the law you have
violated the constitution and you have
violated something very fundamental
about what it means to be american that
is a slippery slope
towards oppression and it must be fought
and my group will fight it absolutely
and i think you're on
fantastic if tragic legal uh grounds to
challenge it keep us posted on that but
you mentioned critical race theory
and this push we see it in schools we
see it in curriculum we see it in our
culture
what could be done on the you're talking
about legal action potentially what can
be done on the legal side if you're to
try to stop this push
well look i happen to believe and a lot
of other people believe and
i think it's probably going to be the
successful argument that critical race
theory
violates federal non-discrimination law
so we have
laws on the books today that say you
can't discriminate based on race
the critical race theory doctrine
requires
everybody to be judged on their skin
color
it's a marxist ideology that groups all
of society into the oppressed
and the oppressors and it says that just
because of your skin color you fit into
one of these two groups
so it's racist against black people it's
racist against latino people it's racist
against white people
because it reduces everybody to their
skin color
and so i do think that the federal
government and this
includes the new regulation issued for
the department of education
can in fact be enjoined on the spaces so
my group just submitted the comment
today which is the first step in the
legal process
objecting to the new department of
education rule mandating
these radical theories in the classroom
and i encourage anyone else who has a
view on it
to submit a comment as yours your right
as an american citizen
and if the department does not change
course then my group will use
every single legal tool available we
wrote a detailed comment
breaking down what's wrong with it you
can read the full comment at aflegal.org
and again that's the first step in the
legal process
and if this administration doesn't back
down and they want to poison
the minds of our children then yes every
legal tool is on the table
aflegal.com uh you can i believe it's
yeah.org sorry
i believe it's regulation.gov i mean i
actually did already submit personally a
comment on this but i feel like yours
probably has god god bless you for doing
that well yours has a lot more legal
health than mine mine was uh let's keep
it close
i doubt it all right stephen miller
thank you very much thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else